unfair finden viele auch das was Frau
Keller jetzt zu sagen hat es geht weiter
um Wohnraum ein großes Problem in
Deutschland wir haben hier auch in der
Sendung über den Fall Lörrach gesprochen
hat seinen Mieter ausziehen um
Flüchtlingen Platz zu machen und jetzt
gibt es ein ähnlichen Fall in Berlin 110
Bewohner des Altenheims wohnen und
Pflege Schillerpark sondern die Koffer
packen um Flüchtlingen zu weichen die
evangelische Landeskirche der gehört das
Objekt und sie sagen Frau Keller das ist
ein Skandal und der Staat der vergesse
zunehmend die eigenen Bürger das ist ihr
Thema ja es ist langsam häufen sich die
Fälle wir haben ja jetzt diesen Fall in
Berlin wo Rentner ausquartiert werden
aus ihrem aus ihrem Pflegeheim und
jemand der einen Verwandten der
Pflegeheim hat weiß was das bedeutet es
stellt sich schlicht die Frage in diesem
Land wer ist eigentlich wichtiger die
Bürger dieses Landes die nach Wohnraum
suchen und Wohnraum brauchen gerade auch
im Alter oder sind es Migranten die in
unser Land kommen und untergebracht
werden müssen und natürlich müssen alle
irgendwo wohnen aber die Frage die
abgewälzt auf die Kommunen die jetzt
händeringend nach irgendwelchem Wohnraum
suchen und wir sehen dass es
offensichtlich lukrativer ist das ist
das perfideste noch in diesem ganzen die
Rentner hier werden ja nicht umgesiedelt
einfach nur so sondern weil es für den
Betreiber dieses Hauses lukrativ ist
Flüchtlinge unterzubekommen anstatt alte
Menschen im Alter in ihrem Pflegeheim in
ihrer gewohnten Umgebung wohnen zu
lassen und wir laufen hier in eine
sozialen Konflikt hinein mit Ansage weil
unsere Regierung immer noch keinen
vernünftigen flüchtlingsgipfel gemacht
hat und wir immer noch die
Migrationspolitik haben der offenen
Grenzen und wenn Sie hier nichts
verändert dann wird eben das passieren
was viele schon seit Jahren sagen
nämlich wir schaffen es nicht sie
glauben also dass dieser soziale
Sprengstoff ist einfach hochgehen wird
ja es ist ein es ich finde es immer
wieder faszinierend wie die Politik
quasi sehenden August zusieht wie sich
soziale Konflikte entwickeln werden es
ist ja für wir sagen wir müssen ja
realisieren diese das ganze
flüchtlingsthematik bezahlen wir ja
schon sowieso das heißt der deutsche
Bürger bezahlt das alles das heißt ja
immer so schön der Staat kommt dafür auf
der Staat sind wir das heißt durch
unsere Steuerzahlungen finanzieren wir
das alles haben aber nichts mehr
mitzureden und wir sehen jetzt dass die
Kommunen unter der Last dessen was sie
wozu sie verpflichtet werden auf die
Kommunen reißen sich ja nicht darum
irgendwie Flüchtlinge
unterbringen zu müssen aber sie sie
werden quasi sie kriegen das zugeteilt
und jetzt haben wir zunehmend nachdem
wir schon andere soziale Probleme haben
wie Gewalt zum Beispiel durch Migranten
haben wir jetzt bekommen wir
Verteilungskämpfe wo ist darum geht kann
ich noch in meiner Wohnung bleiben oder
werde ich ausquartiert und saß auch
tatsächlich mit der Aussage weil
stattdessen Flüchtlinge untergebracht
werden ja was glaubt denn eigentlich
eine Regierung was das mit den Menschen
macht das ist quasi nach dem der
Sündenbock wird quasi dort einquartiert
der hat es warm und wir bezahlen das
noch alles und ich muss wegziehen und
das sind soziale Konflikte die man sich
eigentlich sparen müsste und ich ich
finde auch dass es die Verpflichtung
einer Regierung ist vor allen Dingen
erst einmal für die Bürger ihres
Landespolitik zu machen die Deutschen
sind hilfsbereit die Deutschen sind auch
Ausländerfeind freundlich wir haben
unglaublich viel getan in den letzten
Jahren aber wir haben jetzt die
Ergebnisse in unserem Land dass wir
unglaublich viele Konflikte und hohe
Kosten haben durch eine
Flüchtlingspolitik der offenen Grenzen
wir sind auch damit wieder einmalig in
Europa alle anderen Länder sagen das
geht so funktioniert nicht und wir
machen weiter damit und es wird
eskalieren also meine Prognose ist dass
wir möglicherweise auch wieder Gewalt
auch auf den Straßen provozieren werden
damit die Bürger werden sich irgendwann
wählen oder sie werden radikale Parteien
wählen weil die die einzigen sind die
die Sorgen ernst nehmen und wollen wir
das denn wirklich also ich frage mich
immer warum man eigentlich obwohl man
den sieht wohin es führt warum man es
trotzdem macht bleiben wir auch mal bei
diesem Fall er hat man in der Hauptstadt
sind alte Menschen die jetzt endlich
auch einen Heimplatz bekommen haben das
nicht einfach sind teilweise über 90
müssen vielleicht auch gebrechliches
irgendwie sich neu organisieren jeder
der ein Familienmitglied hat und diese
Reise schon mal begleitet hat weiß das
ist für alle eh schon herzzerreißend und
es ist sehr sehr schwierig diese große
Umstellung ein Umzug irgendwie so
sowieso noch mal zu bewältigen Frau
Kelle sagte gerade sie hat das Gefühl da
werden zu nehmen die Menschen im Stich
gelassen teilen Sie diese Bedenken ja
tue ich und es ist wieder einmal mehr
ein Beispiel dass Deutschland als
schlechtes Beispiel vorangeht dass man
Menschen helfen soll die wirklich Not
haben und aus dem Ausland zu uns kommen
und es sich hier auch wirklich
integrieren wollen da kann er keiner was
dagegen haben aber das passiert hier
nicht das ist alles sehr unkontrolliert
und auch sehr linkslastig gesteuert und
dann mache ich mir natürlich auch so
sorgen hängt auch damit zusammen
natürlich habe ich Familie ich habe zwei
kleine Kinder und man kriegt immer mehr
mit was das so alles passiert Freiburg
ist ja auch so eine Hochburg auch für
Kriminalität bei uns regieren auch die
Grünen ich habe doch grundsätzlich doch
gar nichts dagegen wenn sie gute Politik
machen aber das funktioniert momentan
nicht mehr so richtig
und die Menschen sind immer mehr
politikverdrossen das beobachte ich
schon seit ungefähr so zehn zwölf Jahren
ich würde sagen seit der Finanzkrise und
wenn das nicht bald besser wird dann
gehe ich da komplett mit das wird
irgendwann eskalieren die Leute machen
sich ja Dampf es wird ja es wird in
irgendeiner Form irgendwo können die
Debatten ja nicht irgendwie unterm
Deckel halten die Leute haben das in
ihrer Nachbarschaft die Leute jetzt
haben wir mal hier nehmen Sie dieses
Altenheim hier in Berlin Wedding 110
Senioren das Hängen 110 Familien dran
darüber wird jetzt diskutiert da
entsteht not da das geht ja nicht
spurlos an den Menschen vorbei und es
wird nicht der einzige Fall bleiben der
hier der Sonne genau und das sind jetzt
nur Sachen die bekanntlich ich schwöre
Ihnen es werden jetzt ganz viele Fälle
werden bekannt werden weil das lukrative
spielt ja auch noch eine Rolle also wenn
es quasi für Hotelbetreiber schon immer
lukrativ waren weil sie ein
Flüchtlingsheim daraus zu machen dass
man jetzt bestehende Institutionen wie
Pflegeheime unser Staat ist so attraktiv
macht stattdessen Flüchtlinge
unterzubekommen dass Pflegeheime
schließen wo wir doch sowieso einen
Pflegenotstand haben ja wohin denn damit
und deswegen sage ich das wird sich
sozusagen rumsprechen und das führt zu
sozialen Neid und es führt zu Recht dazu
weil die Leute sich fragen wofür sie
eigentlich noch eigenverantwortlich für
ihr Leben sorgen sollen wie sie das
machen sollen und was ihre Regierung
eigentlich hauptberuflich tut die Frage
leite möchte ich einmal Entschuldigung
direkt weiterleiten weil wir hier
darüber gesprochen haben verschließt die
Regierung ihre Partei ich muss noch mal
sagen sitzt damit am Tisch ähm zu sehr
die Augen davor wir haben hier Worte
gehört wie Politik Verdrossenheit wir
kreieren in sozialen Sprengstoff der
werden dann andere Parteien gewählt hat
man das wirklich so auf dem Schirm
verliere die Menschen wir müssen in
diesem Jahr ein Kurswechsel hinbekommen
eine Migrationspolitik das heißt weniger
illegale Einwanderung Sozialsysteme mehr
reguläre Einwanderungen Arbeitsmarkt und
wir haben eine gesetzespakete in diesem
Jahr vor genau daran müssen wir arbeiten
im Land hier aber auf europäischer eben
überall auf Dauer können wir diese
Flüchtlingsströme so nicht verkraften
wir können Sie auch nicht mehr
integrieren man darf er nicht vergessen
wir haben eine Million ukraineren
Ukrainer hier dass das zusätzlich zu den
anderen Flüchtlingen die kommen ist
irgendwann nicht mehr Stammbar und die
Kommunen merken das und vor allem glaube
ich dass haben wir hier auch
angesprochen fürchten die Menschen es
ist mehr solche Beispiele geben wird wir
haben jetzt Lörrach angesprochen wir
haben das Seniorenheim angesprochen ich
glaube da hilft es auch gar nicht mehr
wenn die Politik sagt wir haben das auf
dem Schirm wir müssen Lösungen erfinden
finden
in der Lage sind also wo man sich glaube
ich besonders auch um das Wohl der
älteren Menschen kümmern müsste wundert
mich das schon sehr dass man solche
Geschäftsmodelle die argumentieren
offenbar dass sie damit mehr Geld
verdienen können
Sie argumentieren dich damit genau
genommen verschweigen Sie das eigentlich
also sie immer man gibt sich immer noch
den sozialen Anschein nach dem
Flüchtlings Politik ist ja auch sozial
also es wird ja auch hier sozusagen mit
einem mit den sozialen Impetus und
moralische argumentiert rechts
ist es aber natürlich eben auch ein
lukratives Geschäft das wird natürlich
nicht gerne betont ich habe halte es
auch für besonders perfide dass wir das
selbst kirchliche Einrichtungen hier
wirkliche quasi sozusagen aufs Geschäft
gucken anstatt auf die Nächstenliebe zu
gucken andererseits warum sollten sie
anders agieren als alle anderen auch
also das ist ja sozusagen
maximieren das kann man als Unternehmen
machen aber nicht als Kirche profitieren
weil der Stadt ist verantwortlich und
jetzt möchte ich einmal ihre Lösungen
hören was würde die FDP machen Frau
Keller hat auch deutlich gesagt wir
brauchen eine Lösung und wir brauchen
eine Strategie die flüchtlingsgipfel
waren nicht genug ja Flüchtling wir
brauchen auf europäische Ebene ganz
klare Übereinkunft das nicht mehr jeder
der auf europäischen Kontinent kommt
hier quasi gleichen Asylantrag stellen
kann obwohl er gar nicht asylberechtigt
ist also ich glaube das Ziel was jetzt
viele europäische Staaten haben dass man
außerhalb Europa prüft und dann Leute
holt die asylberechtigt sind weil sonst
immer das Problem dass wir mit der
Abschiebung nicht hinterherkommen wir
haben ungefähr 300.000 ausreichend
ausreisepflichtige Menschen in
Deutschland und wir schaffen eigentlich
mal zehn Prozent im Moment
zurückzuführen und das müssen wir
umdrehen und ich glaube da muss auch
manche Anreiz beseitigt werden weil wir
die wirklichen Flüchtlinge die in
Flüchtlingslagern sind die vielleicht
medizinische Betreuung bekommen müssen
die würde ich gerne im Rahmen der
kontingentlösung herholen wie das andere
auch machen aber nicht dass die
Schlepper entscheiden wer nach
Deutschland oder werden Europa kommt
aber aber wenn ich ja ein bisschen
Wasser in ihren FDP rein äh Gießen darf
das Problem ist doch irgendwie ist es
ist nicht eine europäische Lösung die
fehlt sondern es ist ein Agieren der
deutschen das fehlt die Europäer sagen
ja schon lange so lange ihr quasi wie
ein Magnet mitten in Europa sitzt und
jedem der es über eure Grenze schafft
und endlich viel Geld aus so einer
Perspektive in die Hand drückt für
nichts ähm können ja auch die anderen
Länder überhaupt nicht verhindern dass
die dass die Migranten die an ihren
Grenzen ankommen einfach weiterreisen
nach Deutschland weil das Deutschland
ist quasi der Garten Eden mitten in
mitten in Europa und so lange wir als
Deutsche nicht agieren können wir
eigentlich die angrenzenden außenländer
nicht verantwortlich machen dafür dass
wir unsere Flüchtlingspolitik nicht
angreifen und wir müssen natürlich 100
Prozent derjenigen wieder aus dem Land
schaffen die hier keine Berechtigung
haben oder die eben auch illegal hier
zum Beispiel illegal werden andere
Länder wie die nordischen Länder sind da
inzwischen zu einer vernünftigeren
Lösung auch übergegangen aber es kann
doch nicht sein als deutscher Bürger
werde ich belangt wenn ich nur auf dem
Einwohnermeldeamt irgendwie falsche
Angaben zu meinem Vornamen mache und wir
dulden in diesem Land auch angebliche
Flüchtlinge die hier Straftaten begehen
und die trotzdem weiter ihr Geld
bekommen und nicht auseinander geschafft
werden das ist ein Hund für unseren
Rechtsstaat genau genommen brauchen wir
eigentlich nichts mehr als dass wir
zurückkehren wieder zu den Regeln die
wir schon immer hatten das würde völlig
ausreichen weil das bedeutet
illegale Zuwanderung ist illegale
Zuwanderung wir gehen hier immer von
Flüchtlingen oder geflüchteten wie es
jetzt so schön heißt mit Verlaub ja ich
würde mal sagen nicht einmal die Hälfte
der sogenannten Flüchtlinge sind in
irgendeiner Form Flüchtlinge es sind
Migranten die sich hier in
wirtschaftlichen besseres Leben erhoffen
das kann ich menschlich verstehen aber
meine Verpflichtung hört da mit Verlaub
auf für Sie dafür sind wir nicht
verantwortlich soweit gehört aber auch
dazu dass Deutschland lange Zeit die
Flüchtlingsprobleme in Spanien in
Griechenland Italien egal waren wir
haben das einfach ignoriert und das
zahlt sich natürlich jetzt im negativen
Sinne aus und deshalb muss es aus meiner
Sicht ah wirklich in Europa eine
konzentrierte Aktion geben dass
Asylanträge von außerhalb des Kontinents
gestellt werden und dass Leute die sich
hier nicht berechtigt aufhalten auch
abgeschoben werden da brauchen wir die
Abkommen mit den Herkunftsländern das
heißt wir Entwicklungshilfe bekommt wer
arbeitsvisas in Deutschland will der
muss auch seine Staatsbürger wieder mit
zurücknehmen das ist jetzt die Aufgabe
wir atmen einmal durch und kommen gleich
zum nächsten
Thema sind viele gelitten werden Corona
mit der Chipstüte vom Fernsehserie
gesessen und dann wollen wir jetzt
wieder rauskommen und es gibt viel zu
besprechen gleich nach einer ganz kurzen
Pause bis gleich wurden sie abgezockt
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie